salut il ya parfois des sujets qui vous
passionne toute une vie pour ma part
c'est le cas pour les chèques alors pas
le jeu d'échecs avec les pièces mais
bien le rater la plantade la
non-réussite l'ami du som on va
découvrir ses implications aujourd'hui
dans nos cerveaux pour cette chose que
l'humanité toute entière expérimente
nous allons aussi parler avec des
personnes que vous connaissez
bernard werber un des auteurs français
les plus lus dans le monde pierre cros
qui est passé de la scène à youtube et
militaires qui produit beaucoup de
fictions sur internet
enjoy phoenix la première fille à se
lancer sur internet il y a dix ans le
puits champion du monde de longboard
dancing et pierce en chef et
propriétaire de nombreux établissements
de restauration parce que vous les
connaissez pour leur réussite dans leur
domaine et beaucoup moins pour leur
échec
vraiment ce thème est beaucoup plus
grand que ce qu'il paraît la chose que
vous ne saviez pas si vous me connaissez
déjà
c'est que j'ai creusé ce sujet depuis
précisément 20 ans et je crois que cette
vidéo va vous exploser quelques neurones
je m'appelle fabien olicard je suis
passionné par l'implication des notions
sur notre mental est aujourd'hui sur mon
quatrième livre qui traite de trois
notions liées l'échec la réussite le
bonheur du point de vue du cerveau et
pour celles et ceux que ça intéresse je
vous en parlerai à la toute fin de la
vidéo pour le moment partant au fond de
notre crâne pour voir ce qui s'y cache
[Musique]
quand on réfléchit à l'échec on a
dépensé des émotions qui remonte à la
surface même parfois des souvenirs aussi
des des sensations en fait ce mot c'est
un déclencheur qui relie beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de choses dans notre
cerveau rien qu'en termes d'émotion il
peut déclencher des angoisses de la
colère de la culpabilité du doubs du
déni du roger pourtant on sent bien
quand on discute avec d'autres personnes
que l'échec
en fait c'est quelque chose de très
multiforme parce qu'il ya la vision
qu'on m'a donnée de l'échec et la vision
que j'ai de l'échec la vision qu'on m'a
donnée de l'échec c'est si tu n'y
arrives pas c'est un échec si tu n'as
pas atteint ce que tu devait atteindre
c'est un échec si tu ne m'aimes pas donc
je compare à un métier tu n'as pas les
chiffres attendus c'est un échec pour
moi le mot échec me fait penser aux mots
hiver dans le dans tous les cycles
il ya quatre saisons une le printemps ou
des choses commencent à monter les teos
est au summum
puis après l'automne où ça redescend et
l'hiver les feuilles tombent là il fait
froid et on passe par une phase où on
peut rien faire on va s'arrêter juste
attendre que les que le printemps
reviennent et que le soleil revient le
mot échec pour moi c'est ne pas gagner
je pense que je me mets dans cette
catégorie de personnes soit je gagne
soit je perds mais peu importe après
c'est à dire que je sois 2e 10e dans un
truc j'ai pas gagné si une conséquence
d'une erreur d'une erreur de parcours
c'est à dire que c est un indicateur
aussi qui va me permettre de revenir un
petit peu sur mon travail et d'analysé
un peu et deux de pointe et les points
faibles et les points à améliorer
t'es pas c'est pas une fin en soi c'est
pas forcément un problème plus un outil
que je vais
que je vais utiliser dans mon processus
d'apprentissage en tout cas dans ma
pratique c'est un petit peu comme ça que
ça marche c'est le fait de s'être fixé
un objectif est de ne pas avoir réussi à
l'atteindre donc de s'être planté
finalement pour moi c'est ça à l'échec
quand on réussit pas à faire ce qu'on
s'était fixés c'était mon meilleur ami
ça sera mon arrivée en france que ça
soit ma vie parce que je suis arrivé à
l'âge de c'est un ami sans parler
français j'ai vu beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup d'échec voire plus et celle que
les autres et j'ai dû m'adapter
le dompter l'accepter est ce que c'est
vraiment étrange que nous définissions
soit si différente pas vraiment
d'ailleurs même le dictionnaire reste
floue dans cette définition en nous
disant échec résultats négatifs d'une
tentative d'une entreprise manque de
réussite des fêtes sur un succès revers
l'échec c'est avant tout notre capacité
à apprendre
tal ben sahar professeurs et psychologue
à l'université de harvard dit la chose
suivante pour améliorer son taux de
réussite il faut d'abord doubler son
taux d'échec si on n'apprend pas échouer
on peut pas apprendre a réussi pense que
l'échec est inévitable à mon sens tu
peux pas grandir dans la vie en ayant
que des réussites c'est impossible
ça arrivera forcément un jour ou l'autre
donc moi j'ai vécu des échecs tout le
monde on a vécu tous alors la caméra tu
en as vécu aussi d'ailleurs ceux qui
connaissent bien cette notion sont
souvent les sportifs de haut niveau qui
sont obligés d'admettre très vite un
processus d'apprentissage passant
volontairement est nécessairement par de
nombreux essais et de nombreux échecs
l'échec pour moi c'est pas forcément un
problème
donc du coup je vais pas aller chercher
une solution je vais plutôt essayer de
l'intégrer
par exemple quand tu es en train
d'apprendre une figure je vais passer
par plusieurs étapes d'échec
forcément même que des fois quand je
réussis une figure du premier coup ce
qui s'appelle un peu le le la chance du
débutant moi je reste un petit peu sur
ma faim quoi je suis un peu frustré même
déçu de ne pas être passé par ces étapes
de d'échec parce que je me dis qu'au
fond de moi je me dis que finalement
cette figure là bas c'est sûr que je la
maîtrise rep a donc du coup il faut
absolument que je passe par cette étape
d'échec plusieurs fois
pour pouvoir en fait éliminer les
mauvaises postures les bas les erreurs
de parcours dont je parle et là on met
déjà le doigt sur quelque chose
d'essentiel l'échec et la réussite sont
les finalités d'un essai l'échec et
l'apprentissage sont donc deux faces
d'une seule et même pièce c'est une
sorte de spécialité de l'être humain qui
est le seul être vivant capable de
s'imaginer dans le futur dans une
situation qui n'existe pas avec des
compétences qu'il n'a pas encore et qui
peut alors à prendre pour que ce qu'il a
imaginé dans le futur devienne réelle et
pour ça il va devoir faire preuve
d'abnégation pour enchaîner les essais
tout processus afin d'apprendre jusqu'au
moment où il va atteindre exactement le
résultat qu'il souhaitait mais ça ne
veut pas dire que c'est forcément
mauvais pour nous ça veut juste dire que
c'est une épreuve qui va nous obliger à
mieux nous connaître et libérale
évidemment c'est de surfer sur cette
descente qui est un échec pour remonter
encore plus haut si je regarde ma vie il
ya eu beaucoup d'autres échecs en dehors
de mes échecs scolaires et michel
professionnels au final j'ai
l'impression que c'est aller vers un
toujours mieux c'est à dire que je
trébuche c'est comme si je trébuche et
dans plusieurs endroits sur la route
mais au final je suis allé quand même
assez loin par rapport à ce que tu me
semblait possible
j'allais beaucoup plus loin ce qui me
semblait possible tout ça ça veut dire
deux choses la première c'est que notre
cerveau est contaminée par une
définition de la société de ce qu'elle
est chez owens et que b j'étais
tellement confronté par l'échec
grâce à mes parents grâce à peut-être
d'autres personnes qui m'entourent et
ont toujours donné le courage de vouloir
continuer je me suis dit et c'est mon
meilleur ami c'est à dire dans tous les
cas toute façon que je fasse dans ce cas
là mais un échec et qu'il faut faire le
dos rond peut-être et un moment donné ça
paie la deuxième chose c'est que si
l'échec à plusieurs formes de
manifestations alors en toute logique la
réussite doit avoir aussi des formes
différentes de manifestations d'ailleurs
qu'un pilote qui a une très bonne
voiture va aller chercher les trois
premières places du podium
par contre un pilote qui a
peut-être la moins bonne voiture du
circuit il va vivre comme une vraie
victoire d'aller chercher la 12e place
par exemple alors que 12e place et
moyens par rapport à 20 mais pour lui ça
va être la victoire de sa vie du coup il
aura battu plein de pilotes qui ont une
meilleure voiture que lui donc ce sera
une victoire
l'échec et la réussite ne sont pas des
mots figé on a décidé de leur mettre des
étiquettes de valeur de les ranger dans
des cases genre mauvais ou bon et quand
je dis nous ça peut être notre famille
notre entourage la culture de notre pays
ça peut être tout ce qui nous entoure en
faites quoi qu'il arrive ça forge est
une croyance ou nous avons décidé
collectivement qu'il était forcément
mauvais deux ratés ou de ne pas aboutir
tout de suite à la réussite est
forcément bien du coup de réussir du
coup comment libérer notre système de
pensée de ce fardeau de ne pas faire
quelque chose parce que j'ai peur de
l'échec qu'on m'a appris c'est je vais
pas faire ça parce que je pense que ça
va pas marcher
et c'est quelque chose et vite banni
parce que l'échec créé beaucoup moins
fort que l'an viii voici l'histoire
d'une autre personne que vous connaissez
aller à la tête d'une véritable
industrie médiatique c'est oprah winfrey
à les classer aujourd'hui la
personnalité afro américaine la plus
riche de notre siècle
mais ce que vous connaissez son plus
gros échec elle a commencé sa carrière
la carrière qu'on lui connaît
aujourd'hui à baltimore en tant que
présentatrice télé et au bout d'à peine
quelques émissions a été viré ils lui
ont dit qu'elle n'était pas faite pour
ce métier
[Musique]
il existe dix grands principes qui
permettent de changer radicalement
l'impact de l'échec sur votre cerveau on
pourrait se dire que c'est une manière
d'atteindre le bonheur en quelque sorte
mais je crois qu'une bonne définition du
bonheur c'est celle que ma formule et
pierre cros que le bonheur c'est un
ensemble auquel tu soustrait les
problèmes et si on peut faire un puits
sans changement de son rapport à l'échec
alors on se libère de ce qui encombre
son bonheur je pense que vous commencez
à comprendre l'idée je vais évidemment
pas vous faire les dix grands principes
ici mais plutôt essayer d'aborder
quelque chose qui va sûrement vous aider
le système des leviers certain moment
quand on commence à travailler avec soit
des producteurs de télévision des gens
de cinéma on s'aperçoit qu'ils veulent
tous se déformer ou faire des trucs pas
tous là pour la plupart des formes et
votre travail et donc à ce moment-là ce
grand luxe et quand je sens que l'autre
personne n'est pas dans le même la même
envie jadis pas grave on va renoncer qui
est très intéressant dans ce que dit
bernard werber
c'est que s'il n'a pas le pouvoir d'agir
pour aller dans l'objectif qu'ils
souhaitent
alors il est prêt à s'adapter jusqu'au
point de renoncer
l'échec potentiel n'était pas le fait
que l'adaptation de ce roman sorte ou
pas dans un autre pays ou sous une autre
forme
l'échec potentiel c'était que quelque
chose d'opposer à ce qu'il voulait au
départ sorte
par extension il faut comprendre que
vous devez prêter de la tension mental
ou émotionnelle qu'aux endroits où vous
pouvez actionner vous même un levier
quelque chose devrait pas ce que je dis
toujours que la un projet il a trois
vies hélas le moment où tu l'écris le
moment où tu le fais par le moment tu
l'écriture prépare en tout cas le monde
le fait et le moment où il est sorti
c'est vraiment trois vies différentes et
dans ces trois vies il ya un milliard de
manière de laisser tomber ou d'échouer
sauf que dans ses trois meilleurs la
queue de kits appartiennent donc en fait
finalement quand le film sort c'est pas
mon échec c'est l'échec aussi que je
partage avec plein de gens qui ont aussi
bosser avec moi sur le film c'est
l'échec d'une idée c'est l'échec d'une
équipe mais c'est aussi l'échec
peut-être de cette histoire là mais en
la mettant ailleurs peut-être qu'elle
peut fonctionner aussi ça peut être
l'échec d'une plate forme ça peut être
léché que de pâles pompe
c'est bizarre de dire ça mais ne pas le
bon public ce n'est peut-être pas la
bonne cible non plus la première étape
m'appartient vraiment de de l'écriture
elle celle là c'est parce que je suis
l'auteur de mes projets j'y tiens
beaucoup
cette étape là c'est sa foire à
l'écriture je vais gérer je le vois
comme ça
la seconde c'est vraiment la préparation
d'un tournage et ça c'est un milliard
d'embûches parce que c'est beaucoup de
gens qui travaillent ensemble sur autour
d'une même idée avec énormément de
contraintes
quand je met fin à un texte j'ai réussi
à écrire quand il ya le clap de fin
on a réussi à le tourner quand il ya le
mise en ligne
on a réussi à diffuser après ça
m'appartient plus le nombre de vues
d'une vidéo des mines ne peut donc pas
être un échec ou une réussite qui la
concerne son objectif réussi c'était de
produire sa fiction comme moi mon
objectif était de faire cette vidéo est
d'ailleurs puisque vous êtes en train de
la regarder
alors j'ai réussi moi en l'occurrence
des échecs j'en ai pas mal mais juste
parce que je me suis rendu compte que
mes espérances étaient tellement haute
que forcément j'allais attendre un échec
c'était complètement inévitable mais
dans la manière dont je faisais les
choses je me rendais pas du tout content
de ça avec du recul j'ai juste appris à
revoir un petit peu mes espérances et à
remettre un petit peu en situation ce
que j'attendais dans projet d'un
événement ou de la vie pour ne pas
mettre mes attentes trotter me dire que
si si ça n'arrive pas et ben c'est pas
grave le fait et il ya moins de chance
d'avoir un échec quand tu penses comme
ça je trouve
en parallèle avec le fait d'avoir la
possibilité de changer les choses ou non
avec les leviers qui dépendent de vous
il faut aussi apprendre à déplacer le
curseur au bon endroit comme l'a dit
marie car même si vous admettez
mentalement que ce qui ne dépend pas de
vous
peut être taxé de réussite ou d'échec il
n'empêche que dans certaines situations
vous pouvez avoir des espoirs ou des
attentes
eh bien ces attentes ne doivent pas être
décidées par vos émotions mais bien par
votre mental tu fais une vidéo que tu
considères un petit peu moins grand
public que ce que tu fais d'habitude bas
une victoire ça peut-être 50000 vue
parce que tu veux dire je pensais
tellement pas intéresser les gens là
dessus que 50 mais vu ce une victoire
parce que tu t'es fixé cet objectif là
c'est très intéressant de voir
d'ailleurs que pierre cros parle de
victoire et n'ont pas de réussite
il a baissé le curseur de son espoir car
il savait qu'il n'avait pas forcément
touché les leviers qu'il fallait toucher
ceux qui maîtrisent pour faire un
maximum de vue le fait que la vidéo soit
vu par un groupe de personnes plus
restreint reste alors une victoire mais
c'est quelque chose que j'ai appris à
voir et surtout par rapport à cette
frustration de l'échec de se dire un
moment donné pourquoi j'ai fait cet
échec là comment je peux dans ma
conscience ou dans l'inconscience
essayer de positiver ça dès qu'on
commence à comprendre comment raisonner
je dis bien comprendre car c'est la
seule manière de couper les réflexe
émotionnel parasites
alors on peut transformer les chèques ou
plutôt la non obtention du résultat
désiré en apprentissage il faut à ce
moment là être hyper pragmatique pour se
concentrer que sur le futur parce que
vous n'avez pas de levier pour changer
le passé c'est pas possible
mais vous avez le levier du présent dans
vos mains ainsi que celui du futur et
c'est là-dessus qu'il faut aller c'est
quand on subit des pensées qu'on n'a pas
désiré qu'on est obligé d'être tout le
temps dans le contrôle émotionnel ou
mentale
il ya quelqu'un qui l'a bien compris qui
le dit mieux que moi c'est l'autre fille
si je devais résumer le danger à mon
bonheur en un mot je dirais le contrôle
on pourrait d'ailleurs allé plus loin en
prenant exemple sur un conte zen qui a
été réécrit par maxime lucas deaux il ya
29 ans en gros c'est l'histoire je
voulais synthétise vraiment mais c'est
l'histoire de quelqu'un très pauvre
bûcheron qui a un cheval blanc
magnifique et il veut pas le vendre
alors que même le roi et lui propose des
fortunes et tout et tout le monde se dit
ce mec là il fout en fait il est pauvre
est située la tâche et malgré tout il
garde son cheval et un jour ils se
réveillent et le cheval est plus dans
les curés et tout village celli a entamé
dit il fallait que tu le vendait ses
aigus écoutez je sais pas si c'est une
bonne chose ou une mauvaise chose
en fait vous tirer des conclusions mais
tout ce que je sais moi c'est qu'il
n'est plus dans l'écurie je sais pas ce
qui s'est passé à ce moment là et puis
pas longtemps après le cheval revient
avec 10 d'autres chevaux et là tu
oublies âge se dit ouah assez incroyable
c'est une super nouvelle en fait c'est
toi qui avais raison et pareil le vieil
homme dit bah en fait non je sais pas si
c'est une bonne chose ou une mauvaise
chose tout ce que je sais c'est que
maintenant il ya dix chevaux en plus
mais je ne sais pas si c'est bon ou si
c'est mauvais et arrêtez d'essayer de
vouloir connaître un livre en ayant lu
qu'une seule phrase et c'est ça qu'il
essaie de le redire et l'histoire va
bien plus loin il ya beaucoup de
rebondissements d'ailleurs celui qui
résume le mieux cette manière de penser
c'est le meilleur joueur mondial de
basket michael jordan qui a dit je le
cite j'ai raté plus de 9000 coup dans ma
carrière j'ai perdu presque 300 matches
à 26 reprises j'ai eu de confier le tir
gagnant du jeu et je les ai ratées j'ai
échoué maintes et maintes fois dans ma
vie et c'est pourquoi j'arrive à gagner
pour l'anecdote il s'était fait
d'ailleurs refusé lors des sélections
pour l'équipe de basket de son lycée
[Musique]
dans cette partie nous allons parler du
coût du bonheur qui est pour certains la
grande réussite à atteindre mais on va
aussi parler de nos gros échecs
respectifs je commenterai pas ces partis
qui sont de vrais témoignages
passionnants
je pense que les situations que j'avais
que plus comme des échecs c'est les
salles vides
au théâtre salle vide ça jamais est
évident dès fois y avait deux personnes
mais c'est ce qui me faisait le plus
peur dans le spectacle mon plus gros
échec je dirais que c'est c'est une
relation en fait qui s'est mal terminée
et qui a été un échec dans le sens où
j'ai mis énormément d'attentes sur cette
relation qui finalement n'a pas du tout
fonctionné ou en tout cas c'est c'est
vraiment terminé de manière assez assez
compliqué et j'ai mis très très
longtemps à m'en remettre
parce que j'avais vraiment l'impression
que j'avais fais moi quelque chose de
mal calé cac40 gendre est en fait c'est
cet échec
moi j'ai quitté mon pays ma famille mes
amis pour mes études pour venir ici en
france faire mon master quand je suis
arrivé j'ai dû j'étais pas dans une
situation très confortable au niveau du
logement donc samassa un petit peu ça
m'a un petit peu détourné l'attention de
mes études et à la fin de l'année j'ai
dû rater deux de deux matières c'était
le responsable de classe qui m'a appelé
pour m'annoncer ça m'a dit voilà l'autre
fille je suis désolé mais tu n'as pas
ton diplôme il va falloir que tu es
rattrap et en gros que tu refasses
l'année je les laisse à massa a été très
violent pour moi un sentiment de
déception j'étais déçu de moi-même je
vivais comme un échec jusqu'au moment où
le spectacle se passe vraiment et qu'en
fait ça se passe bien et que encore une
fois là le curseur il a un peu descendu
parce que tu peux par une ambiance de
feu à cinq personnes dans la salle mais
par contre
naturellement en tant qu'objectif y
baisse si la soirée se passe bien tu
peux vite passé ton objectif de
l'ambiance et se dire mais au final ça
s'est beaucoup mieux passé que ce que je
pensais donc que ce que ce qui m'aurait
rendu malheureux et tu peux retrait vite
résoudre ce problème
citons curseur site accepte de baisser
un peu ton curseur dans ta tête et même
si c'était dur sur le moment c'est vrai
qu'avec du recul parce qu'aujourd'hui
c'était quand même là quelques années je
sais absolument aujourd'hui ce que je ne
veux pas et ça c'est super difficile de
le savoir
quand on sait pas confronté à un échec
justement à quelque chose qu'on voulait
vraiment pas il faut il faut le vivre
pour s'en rendre compte
donc même si c'était très dur
aujourd'hui quand je me mets en relation
avec quelqu'un que ça soit en couple ou
alors de manière amicale
je sais ce que j'attends des gens et je
sais aussi sur tout ce que je ne veux
pas qu'il se passe j'étais en fac de
droit
j'ai échoué un mon passage en à l'oral
j'étais venu à 9h au l'examen mais avec
mon nom qui commence pour lettre w
à 13 heures moins le quart gt gt passer
aucune aucune épreuve chez j'ai
énormément d'échec je me livre rarement
là dessus surtout un échec si je devais
en choisir un j'ai une
grosse rupture amoureuse il ya trois ans
très grosse coupure un truc vraiment qui
fait mal je dois en échec partagé dans
une rupture c2 et vraiment je pensais
que je me relèverai pas me relève repas
oui c'est plus français et là il ya un
prof qui sort épuisé qui était un prof
de droit qui dit aulas j'ai fait un an
maintenant j'en ai marre et puis il
reste combien d'élèves haïr est ce que
vous bon ben je vous prends tout de
suite dès que j'ai fini avec cet élève
et là il ya le prof de droit civil qui
seraient faits il reste qu'il a il reste
que vous bougez là j'en ai marre bon bah
vous passez tout de suite je vais
écouter il y a un petit problème c'est
que j'ai déjà dit oui aux profs de droit
pénal et ledit film dit attendez ici on
n'est pas au bal vous n'avez pas
réserver vos places sur vous passer avec
moi tout de suite pour tours à 6010 ça
soit je vous mets 1 0 qui élimine a toi
jéjé méfie on s'est séparés genech
aymaras et pour oublier que j'en chie
aymaras je me suis mis à bosser et à me
dire je vais réaliser mes rêves
alors je vais voir le prof de droit
pénal j'ai débuté hier le pauvre droit
civil qui m'ont dit que ce soit je passe
avec lui soit il met un zéro qui
éliminatoires je fais dit le prouvent
dobra civilisation pour plus malin que
le droit pour des droit pénal
je fais écouter c'est très simple si
vous allez avec lui qui n'allait pas
avec moi c'est moi qui vous met un zéro
qui éliminatoires aussi hélas il a aucun
témoin de la situation
j'ai un grand patron de solitude le
droit civil apporte en plus de points
que le droit pénal je suis allé aux
droits civils et gu10 éliminatoires du
droit pénal et là je suis rentré je me
suis dit je crois que le droit c'est pas
pour moi et aujourd'hui je vis ma vie
telle que je l'entends et ça se trouve
je ferais pas mais fiction je ferai pas
j'aurais pas rencontré des gens
extraordinaires j'aurais pas refait ma
vie si j'avais pas eu cet échec il ya un
processus que j'ai appris de ma mère qui
permet de mettre tout à plat en fait
quand j'ai eu ma mère au téléphone il
dit pourquoi tu as raté ton diplôme est
ce que est ce que tu es motivé pour
reprendre combien ça va coûter combien
de temps ça va prendre
et donc en fait on se posant ces
questions là c'est des questions
pratiques 1 c
ça m'a permis en raccrochant ça m'a
permis juste de retour de tout reprendre
de prendre un peu de recul par rapport à
la situation et de mode il m'a
finalement en fait c'est pas fait pas la
fin du monde quoi c'est si je fais un an
en plus c'est pas très grave je vais pas
bosser tout de suite je vais travailler
après et alors et j'ai repris j'ai
repris l'année j'ai rattrapé mais de
matières j'ai eu mon diplôme j'ai
commencé à travailler puis voilà et la
vie continue
la chance que j'ai eu c'est que j'ai
toujours eu une famille qui va toujours
entouré voilà pour l'école parce que
l'école j'étais en échec après plus tard
avec le temps grâce à l'apprentissage et
grâce à votre travail j'ai rencontré
d'autres personnes se soient des paysans
des producteurs les gens qui font mon
métier parce que moi je fais juste un
passeur l'argent peut pas acheter des
choses qui font que tu es trop par
contre il peut soustraire les problèmes
qui font qu être malade
les jeux pas des impôts les taxes les
amendes papier etc
quand tu as de l'argent tu peux te dire
non à tout ça c'est moins un problème
qu'avant et je soustrais tout ça à mon
ensemble de choses qui font dans la vie
je peux être bon et moi pendant
longtemps je culpabilise et vachement de
bad de d'être égoïste mais à un moment
j'ai vu aussi autour de moi des schémas
comme ça qui se mettait en place et j'ai
vu à quel point les gens étaient
malheureux alors qu'ils avaient tout
pour être heureux l'argent le bébé la
maison le chien tout tout tout tout tout
est en fait tu te rends compte que d'un
derrière peut-être que cette personne
elle avait envie de faire le tour du
monde avait envie d'être prof d'anglais
je sais pas où tu vois tu sais pas en
fait et je pense que c'est juste la
société qui nous met tellement de
pression pour que l'on nous fasse croire
que le bonheur c'est ça qu'en fait on
est persuadé que le bonheur c'est ça
alors que pas du tout chacun doit se
créer son bonheur tout simplement pour
moi la notion de réussite n'est pas une
notion de groupe de croissance
permanente
c'est une notion d' équilibre ce qui est
important c'est d'être en équilibre avec
le milieu c'est pas être dans un
processus de croissance mais je crois
que toute personne qui est un processus
de toujours plus qui veut toujours plus
d'argent toujours plus de d'objets de
luxe toujours plus
deux signes de pouvoir cette personne va
être malheureuse alors que se contenter
de ce qu'on arrête moi je me contente de
ce que j'ai là tel quel si tous arrêter
ma carrière s'arrêter et si tout ce que
j'ai entrepris s'arrêter je considère
que j'ai eu ma part de gâteau que ça me
suffit après continuent d'arriver c'est
la cerise sur le gâteau c'est dur c'est
cadeau pour l'instant la solution que
j'ai trouvée c'est de sortir d'être avec
des gens de pratiquer mon sport de deux
d'être d'or voilà et de juste vivre ma
vie en fait d'essayer d'aller chercher
c'est justement ces moments de bonheur
non et non j'allais dire ailleurs que
chez moi ben non on peut quand même on
peut être heureux chez chez soi quoi
alors la définition du bonheur pour moi
c'est à voir les gens qu'on aime qui
nous aiment en bonne santé
voilà grâce à mes enfants grâce à mon
travail grâce à mon quotidien
grâce à mon histoire pour moi le bonheur
est dans la conscience ou dans
l'inconscience elle pourrait être dans
l'instant je pense qu on oublie souvent
ce mot l'instant elle est gratuite
on doit à personne son bonheur et ça il
faut pas l'oublier
là pendant des années je me suis
vraiment mis à fond dans le boulot parce
que j'étais persuadé que le bonheur il a
gelé atteindrait que si je réalise tous
mes rêves mais j'avais oublié que tous
mes rêves s'était pas que dans le projet
en fait et je me suis souvenu a pas
longtemps quand on écoute ses
témoignages on se rend compte donc d'une
chose le bonheur c'est pas une émotion
c'est un état c'est une situation et si
l'accomplissement où la réussite ne sont
pas des émotions il devient évident
qu'il est anormal d'en mettre sur
l'échec et surtout de rester bloqué
dessus plutôt que de se concentrer sur
les leviers qu'on a pour le futur voici
un autre cas d'école très intéressant
spielberg
je vais vous raconter ses débuts très
rapidement il a enchaîné les échecs
scolaires il s'est fait licencier trois
fois de la télévision c'est quand même
un univers proche de là où il voulait
être ensuite il a fait un travail en
tant que directeur il a ensuite voulu se
reconvertir et reprendre ses études
qu'il a abandonnées parce qu'il les a
également raté dans chacune de ces
histoires j'ai pris bonne enterrement
des personnes qui sont respectés pour
leur succès au point qu'on parle jamais
de l'histoire conte
qui les a menés là où il voulait en fait
c'est ça le plus intéressant on peut pas
juger d'une situation si on prend pas
honnêtement en compte tout le parcours
qui a été emprunté
parce que si on enlève un décidément
avant et bien la situation que parfois
on peut même leur envier elle n'existe
pas avant de passer à la suite je prend
10 secondes pour remercier les
intervenants de la vidéo les chaînes
youtube de pierre cros enjoy phoenix et
et militaires sont dans la description
je vous invite à aller les voir
tout comme le prochain roman de bernard
werber la planète des chats qui vient de
sortir le compte instagram de lotfi où
vous allez peut-être découvrir sa
discipline
hyper stylé du longue bar dancing et
bien sûr le compte instagram de pierre
sangle où vous allez peut-être découvrir
une cuisine aussi saine et naturelle que
son chef
ce n'était pas un exercice simple de
leur demander de nous parler de chose
d'aussi intime et leurs retours ont été
très précieux pour mettre en perspective
leur réussite à tous dans leur domaine
dans cette vidéo
[Musique]
vu la durée de la vidéo je pense qu'on
pourrait faire un sujet de 10h sur
l'alchimie cérébrale de l'échec de la
joie de la réussite et du bonheur et je
vous l'avais dit j'ai un nouveau livre
qui sort ce 24 septembre etc est
sûrement la plus grande fierté avec le
précédent également mais surtout ma plus
grande angoisse aussi pour être très
honnête avec vous quand j'ai sorti mon
livre sur le temps j'avais peur qu'on se
demande pourquoi j'écrivais un ouvrage
comme ça parce qu'il s'agissait d'une de
mes facettes que vous connaissez pas au
final vous l'avez super bien accueilli
et encore aujourd'hui je suis vraiment
aux anges de voir à quel point vous en
êtes servis donc le nouveau le bonheur
est caché dans un coin de votre cerveau
c'est pire que ça comme émotion pour le
coup parce que dedans je prends en
exemple mon histoire mes échecs les plus
douloureux dont deux que j'avais essayé
d'enfoncer très loin dans ma mémoire
pour jamais en parler et pourquoi j'en
parle parce que je ne pouvais pas être
honnête sur les travaux que j'avais fait
pour changer mon rapport au bonheur à
l'échec à la charge mentale à la
souplesse cérébrale à la réussite et
c'est sans faire tomber les barrières de
ma propre intimité en fait si je
partageais pas à ma propre histoire un
exemple il y avait aucun intérêt ce que
vous allez lire et pour l'anecdote vous
allez lire certaines pages où j'ai eu
les larmes aux yeux d'émotion en me
disant je pose ça là devant tout le
monde
je crois qu'au fond de moi je pensais
écrire ce livre bien plus tard dans ma
vie et puis c'est sorti là j'ai terminé
de l'écrire pendant le confinement
j'avais l'espoir de me dire que si je
vous donnais mes recherches de la
manière dont on peut de dépolluer le
cerveau qu'on peut comment on peut le
décontaminer comme je l'avais fait aimer
vrais souvenirs sans aucune censure
alors ce livre allait être le lift qui
allait le plus vous être utile parmi ce
que j'écris voilà une partie du sommaire
simplifier le crédit qu'on voyait rien
donc là vous avez en post prod et une
partie du sommaire simplifiez vous
pouvez le précommander dès aujourd'hui
dans toutes les librairies qui ont bien
besoin d'être soutenu en cette période
où la rend également en ligne sur toutes
les enseignes habituelles il sort
officiellement le 24 septembre en france
en belgique en suisse
comme toujours quelques semaines plus
tard au canada bien sûr au format papier
au format numérique sur toutes les
plateformes habituelles et bientôt en
livre audio sur toutes les plateformes
de livres audio pomme mes livres
précédents
et oui c'est encore moi qui vais le lire
avec ma voix mais voilà je crois que
j'oublie rien pour les dédicaces je fais
toujours des dédicaces à la fin du
spectacle qui tourne toujours en
respectant les normes sanitaires
pour les dédicaces en librairie je vous
tiendrai au courant sur les réseaux
sociaux et sur mon site internet c'est
un livre que j'ai écrit
grâce à vous et vraiment pour vous
l'aventuré littéraire que je suis avec
vous depuis 2010 est allé folle parce
que vous la souteniez depuis le départ
je le sais donc un simple merci beaucoup